I decided to apply to Stanford in the
first place to improve my negotiating
position with my current employers and I
had no idea at the time
what Business School is gonna be about I
don't think anybody does before they
come you know now at the end of two
years I know that my mind has been
changed the way I think about the world
has been changed the belief I have in
myself and the possibilities that I
think are out there and there's no way
you can really tell somebody that ahead
of time
Stanford really stood out as a place
that had a community a place where
people knew each other on a first-name
basis they enjoyed hanging out with each
other it also offered a lot more
flexibility than some of the other
schools flexibility in terms of being
able to take the classes you want to
really manage your own academic
experience get what you want out of the
program I came to Stanford because I
felt that it was the place where I could
really design a curriculum and an
experience based on my prior experience
and my strengths and really flesh out
the areas where I need to improve and a
small-size be coaching and mentoring
from my leadership lab fellow all the
way to my first year advisor and the
relationships that I thought I could
develop with the faculty which in fact
came into fruition I thought was really
one of the main reasons why I chose
Stanford you know Stanford sort of won
the day when it came from Miami at
weekend and it was unlike any other
school in that everyone I talked to from
fellow admits to admission people to
staff people here which this seems so
concerned and so passionate about my
development and what I was going to get
out of the experience and and then we
know what I could bring to Stanford
Business School and it just really
struck me because it felt really
personal there was this ability I think
to connect and part of that to class
size and part of that I think is just
the people the sort of people that are
drawn to at Stanford Business School
it's very overwhelming coming to the GSB
in the beginning you're surrounded by
people that have started businesses
people that are children of prominent
politicians around the world have just
had amazing careers and you walk in and
you feel like how do I fit in here but
at the end of the day everybody is just
your friend
so when you're in class you and your
jeans here and your t-shirt and
everybody's discussing the same cases
and nobody nobody down plays anybody
else has experienced and they really
want to get to know you as a person I
just felt it was important that I go to
a school with a strong mission and I
also felt that the small size would be
really sort of conducive to the way that
I learned my husband and I know that we
want to stay in the Bay Area and so one
the opportunity to stay in this
wonderful environment and then also just
the chance to build a really strong
professional network in the area where I
know I'm gonna live being here creates
this unique exposure to different
cultures but also to different
backgrounds people that come from very
different companies and very different
work and tasks in their life to what I
did before what ever heard that although
that could be done that's one side the
other side is a getting exposure to
cases cases that study cases and the
managers of companies heõs and people
from companies that come here also
professors experience and being here at
the valley also gives you a great
exposure to companies I went to business
school to start a Social Venture to
fight extreme poverty in Africa and I
needed to go somewhere that valued
social innovation and entrepreneurship
because that was my only purpose for
coming here and Stanford just stood out
way ahead of its peers in those two
categories and one more thing in
addition to that is that the loan
forgiveness program you know I I never
could have come to the Stanford GSB if I
didn't have that guarantee that my loans
would be paid for because I'm gonna be
working in the nonprofit sector not
making as much money and I also come
from a pretty humble background so I
didn't have the money to pay off the
loans but the loan forgiveness program
allows me to get this high quality
education and all these amazing
resources and network and the alumni
network to enable me to carry out this
venture I didn't see so much of
virginity for growth in my country so I
wanted to move to the US and the best
way to get into was to was through
having an MBA from a top university and
I think that from the beginning
my first choice was 1040 is neat I
cannot overemphasize the value of your
peers here and I think that's what
really sets this place apart is just the
openness and the willingness for people
to teach one another and to learn the
weather is fantastic I I went to that
other school in Boston and I have to say
I'm pretty happy being here right now
when I was applying to business schools
I heard a lot of alumni who would say
this they said oh I wish I could go back
and now that I'm here I understand how
someone could sit at their desk 20 years
later as a CEO and say I wish I could go
back